people across the valley honored a
family who lost so much today a week
after seven members of the zacharias
family were killed in a mass casualty
crash in north las vegas clark county
leaders came together to honor them and
speak out against speeding on our
roadways madison kimbrough joins us live
near cheyenne in commerce with more on
tonight's vigil madison
yeah hundreds of people coming together
gathering around to participate in a
caravan vigil that happened this
afternoon you can take a look at the
memorial adding to this massive display
of flowers mementos and candles to honor
the seven lives taken in the crash
people had pay attention and they have
to do something like what they say they
had to do something to
this don't don't keep happening herlinda
zacarias a grieving mother calls for
change after seven of her family members
including her children were killed this
breaks my heart i just have not stopped
thinking about it ever since it's
happened the community also still
reeling over last saturday's fatal crash
on cheyenne and commerce in north las
vegas it touches everybody in the
community and i can't think of a single
person
that
looked at this
at just another
event this is this one really hits the
bone
saturday a caravan vigil honoring the
zakarius family cars made their way from
cheyenne sports complex over to the
crash site several doning red shirts
that read stop speed it's just so hard
because we've seen the kids we've met
the kids and
what the family is going through right
now is just
there's no words and city leaders
acknowledging that change must come in
order for speeding fatalities to stop
across the valley it's a huge
conversation that you know
we'll have to talk with our state and
federal leaders and it just goes bigger
than what we can do and also with our
law enforcement agencies
another vigil will be held tomorrow for
the family at the mlk statute in north
las vegas that's going to be from 4 30
to 6 at night that's open to the public
as well reporting live from commerce in
cheyenne madison kimbrough live local
now